[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour ce rendez vous
hebdomadaire des questions d'actualité
au gouvernement
dans dix minutes les sénateurs vont
interroger interpellé les ministres
au menu de ces questions les
conséquences économiques du coc vie
notamment la crise chez renault mais
aussi bien des questions sur les
banlieues sur les violences policières
ou encore les municipales on va
commencer par parler de ce sujet des
violences policières à l'étranger avec
la morge de djordje floyd et les
manifestations anti racistes qui se
poursuivent aux états unis mais aussi
les répercussions en france je suis avec
esther benbassa sénatrice écologiste de
paris bonjour un jour vous étiez hier
dans la rue dans les manifestations à
l'appel et bien du collectif pour la
famille de adama traoré
peut-on pour vous vraiment faire un
parallèle entre la sphère jones floyd et
la sphère adama traoré
enfin on ne va pas faire de parallèle
parce que ce n'est ce n'est pas
exactement le même qu'en mai et bien oui
là c'est georges floyd et adama traoré
si on se réfère à la dernière
expertises sont morts par suffocation
sous les coups à damas des gendarmes et
floyd des policiers bien sûr les
violences policières aux états unis ce
n'est pas nouveau et en france n'est pas
nouveau du tout non plus moi la veille
j'ai été a bondi à la demande de la
famille de ce jeune fille d'ariel des
années qu'elle
avec 30 jours d'itt été et qui doit
subir une opération c'était un gamin de
40 kg mais n'a provoqué à nouveau ces
manifestations ici à paris le la sphère
jones floyd et bien on a vu et bien les
mêmes mots sur les pancartes
ici à paris et au contraire les
syndicats de police vous disent bien non
ce n'est pas du tout la même chose il
faut pas importer le problème raciste
américain en france n'est pas le même
sujet est ce que vous leur répondre et
goûter je ne dirais pas que tous les
policiers sont racistes mais il y à du
racisme dans la police on ne peut pas à
nier ce fait on a été le cas dans ses
affaires en france a fait écouter à en
général en général les personnes assises
et sont déjà contrôlés six à huit fois
plus que les autres c'est un contrôle au
faciès n'est ce pas et qui est très
gênant et très intimidant et mois déjà
en 2011 j'avais déposé une loi au sénat
pour que qu'il n'y ait plus de contrôles
au faciès et pour cela j'avais demandé
l'établissement de récépissé alors on ne
peut pas nier ce fait mais il faut se
dire que l'ombre de georges floyd plane
sur la manif bien et que ça va continuer
à planer et je crains que les banlieues
ne s'enflamme si le gouvernement ne
tienne pas un discours équilibré
parce que là on est au bahreïn en raison
non on est en train de réduire la
manifestation d'hier à
holy fifi qu'il y a eu à la fin qu'il y
ait eu des violences à la fin je les
regrette
à 9h moi je suis parti parce que je
sentais que partout néanmoins sa santé
le lui ont bien sûr à la fin de cette
manne huile ne pas réduire l'arrivée
dans les conditions que nous connaissons
la peur de la maladie 20001 peut-être à
brens de lille personne
ensemble il ya l'on ne pouvait pas jeter
une vous entendez aussi les personnes
qui disent ces manifestations elles ne
sont pas autorisées dans le contexte
actuel ce n'est pas normal qu'il y ait
autant de personnes qui se rassemblent
qu'est ce qu'ils vont voter c'est pas
normal d'accord je suis d'accord c'est
pas normal
alors que c'est pourquoi ils sont ils
sont tous fous ils sont allés parce
qu'il voulait attraper le colonat virus
non mais enfin il faut se dire que les
gens ont pris des risques il y à un
rejet de la police qui est énorme
moi je suis pour une police qui protège
tant que c'est la police ne deviendra
pas le symbole de la pro d2 protection
et qu'on ne reviendra pas aux gardiens
de la paix il y aura d'autres
manifestations malgré l'interdiction
merci beaucoup esther benbassa d'avoir
répondu à mes questions
on va continuer ainsi interview alors
que cette séance de questions
d'actualité va commencer dans quelques
minutes
je suis avec françois patriat le
président du groupe de la république en
marche ici au sénat françois patriat on
va parler avec vous des municipales il
ya la multiplication des alliances de la
république en marche avec la droite on
en parle beaucoup strasbourg bordeaux
clermont ferrand le 5e arrondissement de
paris par exemple est-ce que c'est à
dire que la république en marche penche
à droite je peux vous dire que dans les
investitures qui ont été faites par la
commission nationale
on a recherché des accords avec des gens
qui partagent nos valeurs
la vision que nous avions deux ni de
droite ni de gauche et de droite et de
gauche
dans ces accords il y avait deux tiers
d'accord plutôt à droite et un tiers
d'accord plutôt à gauche
verseauaujourd'hui que les accords à
droite sont plutôt tenu tenu dans les
engagements
je le vois par exemple chez moi à mâcon
ou à vous ou d'autres en bourgogne
franche comté où les accords sont tenues
respectée avec des places largement
ouverte aux marchés il ya d'autres
territoires où la gauche elle poussé par
ses propres militants chez son temps je
les connais par ailleurs ne veulent pas
d'accord avec avec nous ne veulent pas
d'accord mais là bas vous il n'est pas
vrai vous qui avez été socialiste la
plus grande partie de votre carrière
politique pendant vous le déplorez cette
situation alors que vous avez été
socialiste je leur dis que je ne vois
des élus je vois des élus socialistes
tu restes de gauche bien entendu
seulement aujourd'hui je pense que le
parti socialiste doit se refonder doit
retrouver à la fois un leader une autre
doctrine l'a pas encore fait il le fera
sans doute dans le futur mais celui
aujourd'hui c'est que la gauche ne veut
pas manifestement travailleurs avec ou
elle refuse surtout les militants qui
sont les plus j'allais dire qu'il faut
les obstacles le plus fort que d'autres
donc c'est normal que les accords mais
avouez que l'accord qui est fait à
bordeaux aujourd'hui l'accord équilibré
que l'accord qui fait à strasbourg qui
permettra demain d'avoir je l'espère un
maire en marche à strasbourg est un
accord aussi équilibré c'est lui qui
était fait à la métropole de lyon
pourquoi avoir exclu gérard collomb dans
ce contexte on entend aussi par exemple
françois bayrou qui estime que cette
décision elle a été brutale qu'elle est
infondée et finalement on voit d'autres
accords avec la droite sur gérard
collomb j'ai vu par plus de réserve mais
je vois que le chemin qui a été parcouru
elle a la voix qui a été priée de des
buses correct et je pense que gérard
collomb aurait dû trouver les moyens de
s'accorder avec les partenaires qui sont
en marche aujourd'hui je crois que c'est
une sur non recevoir de part et d'autre
part ailleurs mais au nom de la
responsabilité
c'est pas le fait d'avoir pactisé avec
la droite je le dire c'est le fait de
l'avoir fait dans le bureau de monsieur
wauquiez
c'est ça qui parlait de wauquiez c'est
pas pareil que la droite juppé pas du
tout un mot sur agnès buzyn toujours une
bonne candidate pour vous à paris on la
voit qui reprend maintenant sa campagne
je crois que
aujourd'hui quel aurait été le sens d'un
nouveau changement de candidat
agnès buzyn effet une campagne digne
c'est une grande dame dans une grande
ville je crois qu'elles portent les
valeurs qu'elle a portée au gouvernement
le fait avec beaucoup de responsabilités
beaucoup de talent par ailleurs je pense
que prend cette élection n'est pas
gagner aujourd'hui mais elle fait une
campagne qui est digne j'en veux dire
quand même que les élections municipales
c'est les élections de stabilité je n'ai
jamais vu aujourd'hui on dit que c'est
un échec pour la commune ce n'est pas
bien sûr mais nous avons quand même
malgré tout je dis beaucoup progressé
parce que jamais je n'ai vu jamais je
n'ai vu un parti ni le parti socialiste
que j'ai bien connu vous l'avez dit ni
la république le rpr à l'époque gagner
des collectivités gagner des mairies
gagner des départements gagner des
régions à trois ans il aura fallu à tous
lui 10 12 ans pour y arriver
donc laissons à la république en marche
le temps d'aller viser voilà les
inquiétudes sur pour la république en
marche sur ce scrutin
juste un mot sur la sincérité du scrutin
est-ce que vous avez encore des craintes
sur la sincérité du scrutin la
participation au 28 juin on sait que
vous auriez été favorable plutôt et bien
à repousser les élections à l'année
prochaine
je le dis je n'y reviens pas je suis je
suis loyal c'est la décision du
gouvernement c'est la décision du chef
du gouvernement
bien entendu je suis loyal et je la
soutiens je continue malgré tout à dire
que dans ce scrutin
il ya quelques obstacles majeurs qui me
paraissent d'abord la rupture d'égalité
entre les candidats que je vois je
reviens aux armements tous les jours qui
vont commencer la campagne et qui lisent
voilà deux mois que nous n'avons pas
existé alors que le maire sortant a
existé il ya une rupture d'égalité
réelle 2-1 scrutin le premier week-end
de départs de juillet et pendant que la
commission denquête va siéger au sénat
ça va des conditions difficiles aussi
donc j'ai émis des réserves je
m'interrogeais je m'interroge toujours
mais je serai loyal vous maintenez vos
réserves mais vous êtes loyal merci
beaucoup françois patriat d'avoir
répondu à mes questions et un vent est
bien d'aller en séance je vais
accueillir et de la sénatrice écologiste
là c'est l'actrice pardon génération du
val de marne sophie tailler polian
bonjour n'ont pas demandé à l'ensemble
de la situation du groupe renault alors
que les salariés de l'usiné de
choisy-le-roi dans le val-de-marne votre
département se sont mises en grève face
à la fermeture annoncée de leur site
vous les soutenez
bien sûr bien sûr parce qu'on voit bien
là que le projet
deux pour que renault et l'industrie
automobile eux affrontent les grandes
transitions à venir la transition
écologique ne ne sont pas à la mesure
des enjeux
et donc c'est forcément sur les salariés
que pèse tout de suite les difficultés
d'une entreprise sans pour autant un
projet industriel qui soit viable
non et les choses ne peuvent pas se
passer ainsi vous ne pensez pas que la
situation financière aujourd'hui de
renault exige des coûts parce que ce
n'est pas tout la survie du groupe qui
est en jeu aujourd'hui ce dont on a
besoin c'est d'une vision renouvelée
pour que l'industrie trouve sa place
dans un nouveau modèle de société qu'ils
soient vertueux en terme environnemental
et qui soit aussi vertueux au niveau
social je ne vous cache pas qu'on aurait
en france un revenu universel
d'existence la situation des ouvriers et
ouvrières actuellement en difficulté ne
serait pas la même et on pourrait
envisager les choses différemment
pour l'instant il y a évidemment d'abord
à faire en sorte que les évolutions de
l'entreprise ne se fasse pas au
détriment des salariés de leurs droits
du est évidemment de l'emploi c'est
essentiel
hier le prêt garanti par l'état 2 5
milliards d'euros pour renault a été
signé ce que c'est pour vous une bonne
chose
c'était vital encore une fois pour ce
groupe on sait qu'ils ne pouvaient pas
faire sans mais l'intervention de l'état
doit toujours être conditionnés et
aujourd'hui on voit bien que les
conditions ne sont pas réunies à la fois
pour assurer à houdain conditions sur
les dividendes sur le maintien du
silence et ce n'est que normal qu'on ne
distribue pas de dividendes alors qu'on
va mettre des gens au chômage
enfin je veux dire c'est juste c'est ça
devrait même endroit même pas avoir à le
demander on ne devrait même pas avoir à
le demander mais ce n'est pas suffisant
qu'est ce que vous demandez nous on nous
demandons enfin moi je demande à ce que
les différents sites soient sauvegardés
à ce qui est un vrai projet industriel
qu'ils soient montés pour assurer
l'avenir notamment pour choisy-le-roi
bien sûr les insultes c'est le site qui
est le plus en danger aujourd'hui pour
renault en france sont bien sûr on pense
à choisy-le-roi immédiatement dans le
département dans le val de marne mais
aussi à maubeuge et à tous les salariés
de renault qui sont inquiets et on les
comprend et bien mairie entend tout se
fait tailler polian d'avoir répondu à
mes questions
on va maintenant rejoindre et bien
l'hémicycle du sénat
où la cloche vient de sonner vous le
voyez gérard larcher est installé c'est
le début de cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
[Musique]
usage
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
notre ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
sous le format adapté que nous avons
défini qui évoluera encore notre séance
se déroule dans les conditions de
respect des règles sanitaires mises en
place depuis le mois de mars avec les
mesures de précaution et chacun
respectera notamment la procédure
d'entrée et de sortie pour les sénateurs
par le couloir du pourtour du haut et le
gouvernement par devant j'aurais salué
les sénateurs qui acceptent d'être
présent dans les tribunes du public qui
leurs sont réservées sont naturellement
pleinement dans l'hémicycle à cet
instant notre séance et retransmise en
direct sur public sénat et sur notre
site internet
je donne la parole notre collègue
olivier léonard pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mes chers collègues la
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur monsieur le
ministre
j'avais prévu depuis plusieurs jours de
vous interroger sur les tensions
grandissantes dans les relations police
citoyens j'avais d'ailleurs signé durant
le confinement un appel donc vous avez
été destinataire avec de très nombreuses
personnalités sur les problèmes de
racisme qui existe au sein de la police
et qu'il me semble urgent d'affronter
avec jr
ceci étant dit je veux aussi bien sûr
affirmé avec force qu'il n'est pas
possible de laisser toute une
institution républicaine la police
nationale et ses agents salis par les
comportements intolérables d'une infime
minorité
nous savons l'importance des missions
exercées par nos forces de l'ordre la
sécurité est en effet le premier des
droits notamment pour nos consignes
lyon les plus fragiles et c'est aussi la
garantie de notre liberté nous savons
aussi combien leur mission est difficile
et malheureusement depuis de trop
nombreuses années
et quelle que soit la couleur politique
des gouvernements les conditions de
travail de nos policiers se dégrade avec
le manque de moyens le manque
d'effectifs
le manque de reconnaissance la pression
liée au contexte politique mouvementée
où le terrorisme
dans ce cadre explosif la dégradation
des relations entre la police
républicaine et nos concitoyens qui
montait durant les semaines de
confinement a été malheureusement trop
souvent relégués au second plan
c'est pour cette raison mais aussi du
fait du contexte international que la
manifestation d'hier devant le tribunal
de paris a trouvé un écho important et
je condamne bien entendu fermement les
violences qui se sont survenus à la fin
de ce rassemblement
il est pourtant impératif urgent de
répondre enfin à la fois aux inquiétudes
des policiers et agir aussi avec force
pour garantir l'expliquent ce nom
l'exemplarité de leur action alors
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
pouvez vous nous indiquer quels moyens
sont prévues pour permettre aux forces
de l'ordre de travailler sereinement et
préciser si le stock de plusieurs
millions d'heures supplémentaires dues
aux agents va enfin être payés enfin
pouvez-vous aucunement me dire quelles
nouvelles actions sont envisagées pour
lutter contre les problèmes de violence
et de racisme au sein de la police
nationale
pour vous répondre la parole et à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur sur
christophe castaner j'avais la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs certain monsieur le sénateur
léonard pour défendre cette institution
cette police républicaine que vous avez
salué dans son quotidien et que nous
saluons tous ici il faut aussi être
particulièrement exigeant
il faut faire en sorte que chaque faute
et il peut y en avoir
chaque accès chaque mot y compris des
expressions racistes fasse l'objet d'une
enquête fasse l'objet d'une décision
fasse l'objet d'une sanction et je suis
sur ce sujet intransigeant parce que et
l'exigence que nous avons vis-à-vis des
policiers qui ferait
c'est garantir justement la sérénité du
travail de l'ensemble de la police et de
la gendarmerie c'est garantir la défense
de cette police républicaine qui au
quotidien combat combat le racisme
combat l'antisémitisme et s'engage au
quotidien pour défendre l'honneur de la
république
c'est ça qui est essentiel il ne s'agit
pas de faire des amalgames mais il
s'agit effectivement de dénoncer tout
propos ou tout comportement s'il ya
faute
elle doit être sanctionnée et elles sont
sanctionnées le défenseur des droits
il y a quelques jours rang des rapports
sur défection plusieurs années les
policiers incriminés ont fait l'objet
d'une peine d'emprisonnement de quatre
mois il ya quelques semaines à marseille
des policiers ont commis des gestes
inacceptables un comportement
inacceptable selon l'addition de justice
un des policiers a été condamné à 40
mois d'emprisonnement pour avoir
transporté une personne contrôlée de
force en dehors de la ville de marseille
ces faits là sont inacceptables ils font
l'objet de sanctions
et donc nous devons être vigilants mais
attentif attentif en nous engageant et
je réponds à votre question auprès de la
police et de la gendarmerie depuis 2010
est le budget la police et gendarmerie a
augmenté d'un milliard d'euros c'est
significatif depuis 2010 est nous avons
lancé un programme de recrutement de dix
mille policiers et gendarmes
supplémentaires sur tous les services
ceux du renseignement mais c'est aussi
de la police de sécurité du quotidien et
monsieur le sénateur pour clore mon
propos je nous renvoie non pas aux
commentaires
mme à la réalité des analyses sérieuses
et récemment l'université du mont blanc
a travaillé sur le rapport entre les
citoyens et la police 48 mille cent
trente quatre personnes ont été
interrogées dans ce cadre là et 85,3 %
de ses 48 mille cent trente-quatre
personnes interrogées ont une opinion
très positive et positive de la police
nationale et de la gendarmerie
c'est aussi ça la réalité ce ne sont pas
les commentaires médiatiques et la
réalité elle ne se fait pas sur les
réseaux sociaux
donner la parole est révoqué en
demandant que chacun respecte son temps
pour éric bocquet pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen
écologistes avaient la parole monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame la
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'économie et des finances le groupe
automobile renault vient d'annoncer la
suppression de 4600 emplois dans notre
pays bien au-delà des effets de la
pandémie en cours nous payons là le
choix des délocalisations massives vers
les pays à bas coûts pratiqués ces deux
dernières décennies les menaces pesant
sur l'avenir de certains sites suscite
on l'a constaté d'énormes inquiétudes
dans les territoires concernés
maubeuge malgré les annonces récentes
mais sans réelles garanties au delà de
2023 choisy-le-roi flins caudan ou
encore dieppe
le chiffre d'affaires de renault fut de
55 milliards d'euros en 2019 l'état
actionnaire annoncé l'octroi d'une
garantie publique de 5 milliards d'euros
monsieur jean-dominique senard président
de l'alliance renault-nissan mitsubishi
déclaré sur france info lundi soir que
cette garantie ne s'accompagnait pas de
je cite de contraintes difficile madame
la ministre quelles contraintes
allez-vous imposées au groupe renault
pour vous répondre
la parole est invendable secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'économie
et des finances on peut dire une chose
avez la parole merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur ben ok je sais
votre attachement à renault vous êtes un
élu du nord le nord c'est notamment
maubeuge s'est notamment doué de sites
qui sont extrêmement importants oui
j'élargis un peu de sites qui sont
extrêmement importants et notamment
maubeuge qui est le site qui produit la
kangoo et qui est un des plus productifs
des sites français aujourd'hui pour
lequel d'ailleurs bruno le maire a réuni
encore hier l'ensemble des organisations
syndicales
les élus pour justement faire prendre
des engagements à renault et je rappelle
qu' hier le prêt garanti par l'état
étaient encore pas signé et ce sont ces
engagements là que nous
prenons en donnant cette garantie jean
dominique senard a été très clair la
première chose c'est que renault est en
grande difficulté
je crois que autour d'eux c'est bon on
peut tous accordés sur cette situation
elle aborde la crise en difficulté cela
avait été indiqué au moment de l'annoncé
des résultats
2019 elle perdait beaucoup d'argent et
elle continue à en perdre dans la crise
dans le cadre de la crise du coc vide
la deuxième chose c'est que renault fait
un plan mondial de réduction des coûts
ce plan il concerne aussi la france mais
par diby d'autres pays le sujet n'est
pas de délocaliser des productions le
sujet de faire face à une diminution du
nombre d'achats de voitures renault peut
produire cinq millions de voitures
malheureusement elle n'en vaudra
peut-être que trois millions trois
millions 2,3 millions 4 cette année on
voit bien l'écart de production par
rapport à ses capacités industrielles
la troisième chose c'est que jean
dominique senard s'y est engagé les
suppressions d'emplois en france ont
vocation à être des suppressions qui ne
s'accompagnait rompt pas de
licenciements secs
c'est son engagement nous le suivrons de
très près c'est notre travail
enfin s'agissant du site de maubeuge
je veux dire ici que là encore il a pris
des engagements fermes visant à en 2023
donner un avenir à ce site et à
continuer et il maintenir des activités
dernier point renault s'est engagé à
relocaliser des productions en france
notamment sur la traction électrique et
à investir dans la batterie électrique
ce projet européen qui est si important
pour notre industrie automobile
monsieur bloquer les sites de production
des modèles twingo clio et dacia sont
implantées en turquie en roumanie et en
slovénie
ces usines tournent 7 jours sur 7 et
sont surchargés il faut décidé de
relocaliser la production de 300 mille
de ces véhicules afin d'apporter de la
commande au site de production de notre
pays et dans le même temps réorienter
ses productions vers des modèles
hybrides électriques et thermiques à
prix modique
ceci aussi afin d'accélérer la
transition énergétique et cela pose
aussi en creux la question du pouvoir
d'achat
personne ne comprendrait que l'argent
public ne servent qu'à accompagner des
suppressions d'emplois notre industrie
automobile mérite un autre développement
un autre avenir et un engagement fort et
déterminé de l'état actionnaire merci la
parole est maintenant notre collègue
viviane artigalas sur le groupe
socialiste et républicain de la parole
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues membres de
la délégation sénatoriale aux outre-mer
je me fais ici la porte parole des mes
collègues de guadeloupe et de martinique
qui s'inquiètent pour l'avenir
budgétaire des collectivités d outre mer
c'est dans un contexte de chute brutale
des rentrées fiscales que le premier
ministre a annoncé ce vendredi une
garantie des recettes pour les autres
maires 110 millions pour les communes 40
millions pour les régions et
collectivités uniques des mesures que
nous avions très tôt proposé et que nous
sommes aujourd'hui satisfait de voir
acté mais vous nous proposez une
enveloppe de 150 millions alors que
notre collègue sénateur georges patient
auteur d'un rapport sur le sujet par le
pour sa part de 200 millions quand
d'autres experts avancent même la somme
de 240 millions nous sommes donc encore
manifestement très loin du compte
outre ces poutres ses premières mesures
des experts mandatés par bercy ont
également commis un rapport qui vous
propose de remplacer l'octroi de mer par
des points de tva supplémentaires madame
la ministre
évitant ce débat d' déstabilisant et
anxiogène nos collègues vous demande
d'écarter cette option mortifère qui n'a
fait l'objet d'aucune consultation au
lieu de reformer le 3 de mer ils vous
proposent de rattraper le niveau des
dotations de péréquation versée dès
cette année les 85 millions d'euros qui
font défaut aux outre mer il vous
suggère de préfinancer le fctva pour
toutes les collectivités ultramarines et
pas seulement pour mayotte
il souhaite que soient versés de manière
anticipée certaines ressources aux
collectivités comme la dgf et que soit
intégralement compensé les allègements
de taxes de séjour et de cotisation
foncière
ils vous demandent enfin d'anticiper la
crise sociale à laquelle feront face les
départements et de supprimer les
contrats du pacte de cahors madame la
ministre
quelles réponses pouvez-vous faire assez
légitime demande pour vous répondre la
parole
les outre bernard girardin vous avez la
parole monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
les mesures annoncées par le premier
ministre vendredi voulez vous en avez
parlé sont des mesures exceptionnelles
historique
vous comme moi nous sommes investis dont
la vie politique depuis de nombreuses
années mois depuis 2000 j'en ai jamais
vu y compris après la crise de 2008
c'est exceptionnel c'est historique et
pour les territoires ultramarins
l'effort est à la hauteur des besoins
vous avez parlé d'un certain nombre
d'évaluations ce ne sont que des
évaluations nous nous sommes
effectivement mis d'accord avec
l'ensemble des collectivités pour avoir
cette évaluation mais de se dire aussi
que le rendez vous il est pour la fin de
l'année
qu'est ce que c'est qui a été enfin
qu'est ce qui a été annoncé par le
premier ministre vendredi et c'est
important de le rappeler
ça veut dire pour les communes des
drames il faut le préciser pour les
communes des drames ça veut dire
qu'elles vont avoir une compensation des
pertes et notamment sur l'octroi de mer
sur le carburant total
qu'est ce que ça veut dire pour les
régions ça veut dire exactement la même
chose
une exception une spécificité pour les
régions ultramarines elle aussi est
laurent cette garantie de prise en
charge par par l'état bien sûr qu'il
faut une évaluation et qu'elles ont été
chiffrés le rapport du député cazenave
nous a servi de base mais les débats
continuent et nous aurons l'occasion
d'en reparler aucune aucune collectivité
n'est oublié je vous rappelle que la
calédonie comme la polynésie ont fait
une demande de prêts garantis par l'état
pour la calédonie ses 240 millions qui
ont été accordés c'était opl fr 2 cette
fois ci nous traiterons effectivement et
nous sommes en négociation la polynésie
opl fr 3 et puis les autres
collectivités les petites collectivités
de 74 sont aussi pris en compte dans
leur spécificité notamment quand elles
ont des ressources qu'ils qui viennent
d'une forme d'octroi de mer ou de taxes
sur les carburants
ce que je veux dire c'est que c'est la
première fois qu'on embrasse la totalité
des territoires ultramarins et qu'on est
aux côtés de tous les territoires c'est
je crois ce dont il faut se féliciter
mais je n'ai pas oublié toutes vos
autres demandes et bien sûr que nous
sommes aux côtés des collectivités
depuis le début j'ai fait en sorte
d'ailleurs que les flics et 210 millions
soit attribuée en totalité aux
différentes collectivités dès le mois de
février
dès le début de la crise pour qu'elle
puisse agir dès la fin de cette crise
dès le confinement pour relancer les
marchés publics pour relancer l'économie
des territoires avec l'agencé française
de développement
on a annoncé 1 milliards de soutien aux
collectivités et aux entreprises qui
sont disponibles à partir de cette
semaine il ya eu d'autres formes
d'accompagnement et je vous rappelle que
gouvernement n'a pas terminé l'ensemble
de ces annonces en la matière puisque le
premier ministre prendra aussi la parole
sur ce sujet le réflexe outre mer il est
là nous sommes aux côtés des
collectivités comme si l'histoire
madame a dit gallas oui merci madame la
ministre pour ses réponses donc on
compte sur vous pour continuer je crois
que je tiens quand même à continuer à
souligner l'urgence ce qui est de
prévenir tous les risques d'un capacité
budgétaire de permettre aux
collectivités d'outre-mer de sortir de
l'ornière et de retrouver des marges de
manoeuvre budgétaires en effet vous êtes
sympas sans savoir que l'investissement
et l'économie des autres merdes dépend
essentiellement de la commande publique
donc nous comptons sur vous pour
continuer à aller plus loin et surtout
ne trouverez pas le débat sur l'octroi
de mer merci beaucoup
mais si la parole est à notre collègue
jean pierre decool pour le groupe les
indépendants vous avez la parole mon
cher que l'oeil pour des résidents
derrière mes chers collègues
c'est un parlementaire quelque peu
décontenancé qu'ils interrogent monsieur
le ministre à propos de la
reconnaissance des élus locaux sans
étiquette
ces élus représentent excusez du peu
près de 85% des élus locaux dans le
département du nord
j'avais plaidé il ya quelques années
avec alex türk mon prédécesseur et la
fédération des élus non inscrits d'une
heure en faveur de l'instauration
officiels de la qualité d'élu sans
étiquette c'était en 2003 en 2010 le
conseil d'état avait rejeté le couple
heureux comme formulées contre
l'impossibilité pour les élus d'être
reconnus et classé comme sans étiquette
ce combat anciens nous pensions le
partager avec vous monsieur le ministre
lorsque mon collègue dany wattebled vous
a interrogé sur votre volonté d'intégrer
cette rubrique
dans les documents des élections
municipales 2020 vous sembliez ouvert à
la discussion à notre écoute
aviez vous dit pour reprendre votre
expression
votre circulaire tant décriée du 10
décembre 2019 apporter un début de
réponse en supprimant le nuance mme en
politique pour les candidats dans les
communes de moins de 9000 habitants
la circulaire a été suspendu par le
conseil d'état celle du 3 février à
rabaisser le seuil aux communes de moins
de 3500 habitants
or chef de canton nous n'avons pas crier
victoire mais nous pensions que le
concept d' élus sans étiquette était
acquis mais depuis quelques jours j'ai
un horrible doute certains maires m'ont
fait part de leur déception de leurs
interrogations
en remplissant le document de
déclaration des résultats
dans celui-ci leur étiquette politique
leur ai demandé y compris dans les
communes de moins de 3500 habitants
ma question est donc clair votre
circulaire du 3 février 2020
s'adresse-t-elle aux déclarations de
candidature et aux documents de
résultats des élections ou
s'adresse-t-elle uniquement au sel
déclaration de candidature il semble que
les interprétations soit différente plus
clairement les élus qui le souhaitent
dans les communes de moins de produits
atteint d'habitants or j'ai avoué
l'arrondissement peut-il choisir de ne
pas avoir de nombreux politiques
je vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole comme monsieur le ministre
d'intérieur vous avez la parole
merci monsieur brison mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le sénateur vous
avez bien compris qu'au moment où je
signais circulaire qui suggérer qu'en
deçà de 9000 habitants c'est à dire un
très grand nombre de communes il ne
s'agissait pas de faire en sorte que les
préfets seul décide à nu en sage
politique est de faire en sorte que la
réalité que beaucoup connaissent ici que
j'ai connu pendant les dix-sept ans où
j'étais maire d'une commune de 5000
habitants ont fait que en réalité on
peut avoir son d'étiquette politique
personnelle mais pas dans sa fonction ni
même dans celle de la liste que l'on
conduisait le débat a eu lieu
il a été très médiatisée très repris et
et je me souviens avoir subi quelques
reproches sur ce sujet là et donc j'ai
abaissé le seuil à 3500 pour exécuter la
décision du conseil d'état
il y à la différence et voulait rappeler
entre l'étiquette politique qui est
déclarative le nuance âge qui relève de
l'appréciation des prêts faits et depuis
longtemps et je crois qu'effectivement
il ya certains
un maire élu qui ne se retrouvent pas
forcément derrière une étiquette
politique donc on les invite à déclarer
leurs étiquettes
ils peuvent effectivement ne pas se
retrouver et les préfets doivent celle
usages et je ne voudrais pas rouvrir ce
débat nuancé mais ce que je veux vous
dire c'est que la règle qui s'appliquera
dans les jours qui viennent ou qui
s'applique aujourd'hui est la même que
celle qui a été retenue en 2014 et les
années précédentes
depuis 2000 14 37 1165 mer et là vous
allez me dire mais c'est plus que le
nombre de mères mais mr qui ont été en
fonction depuis 2014 du fait de
démissions de décès de remplacement de
mr ont fait l'objet de ce nuance h par
les préfets et 26 1689 soit 72% ont été
classés divers alors certes ce n'est pas
la population sans étiquette mais je
pense que vous retrouverez dans cette
appellation divers qui ne permet pas
d'identifier politiquement sur le schéma
que nous connaissons dans notre
représentation nationale ou dans les
partis politiques mais qui correspond à
l'expression des mères qui ne veulent
pas se reconnaître dans telle ou telle
étiquette politique et les instructions
que je donne au moment où je vous
réponds et que je confirmerai si c'était
nécessaire c'est que les préfets doivent
être à l écoute des maires désignés par
le conseil municipal et que la
qualification divers relève de leur
propre appréciation et que nous devons
entendre
merci la parole et à notre collègue
arnaud bazin pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur monsieur le
ministre se développe en france chez
certains de nos concitoyens un sentiment
d'impunité qui n'est d'ailleurs pas
qu'un sentiment ici développe une réelle
impunité ou la violence et la menace ont
depuis longtemps pris la place de la loi
et des forces de l'ordre
de plus en plus spectatrice de situation
qui leur échappe
l'autorité de l'état n'est à leurs yeux
plus qu'un mot à force de laisser faire
d'excusés de ne rien faire
l'état a perdu le contrôle nous
récoltons les fruits amers de nos
renoncements une de nos collègues
jacqueline eustache brinio sénatrice du
val d'oise est aujourd'hui victime de
cette violence et de ces intimidations
qui touche tout ce qui représente l'état
où les pouvoirs publics pour contester
une décision prise par la mairie de sa
ville
ceux qui ne l'acceptent pas ont choisi
de s'en prendre à notre collègue
vendredi elle a été copieusement insulté
lundi un groupe d'une quarantaine de
personnes a fait le siège de son
domicile l'empêchant de sortir de chez
elle alors jusqu'à l'a menacé de s'en
prendre à sa mère âgée qui habite un
quartier hlm de la ville avant que ce
groupe qui déambulait dans la ville
n'arrive devant son domicile la police
municipale avait pourtant prévenu la
police nationale de ses intentions
hier ce même groupe a recommencé sa
bruyante déambulation bloquant la
circulation
s'installant sur plusieurs giratoires
pour finir par revenir devant le
domicile de notre collègue et il proféré
de nouvelles menaces
aujourd'hui notre collègue ne peut plus
circuler librement dans sa ville hier
une manifestation interdite en plein
état d'urgence sanitaire qui a réuni
vingt mille personnes devant le palais
de justice de paris a dégénéré la
justice y était accusé de couvrir la
gendarmerie dans un dossier qu hélas au
plan local je connais trop bien qu'elle
inversion des valeurs ce sont désormais
les voyous qui tiennent la dragée haute
aux représentants de l'état aux forces
de l'ordre
l'impunité leur donnent toute leur force
ces voyous savent qu'ils ne risquent
rien la politique de votre gouvernement
est de vider les prisons
d'où ma question monsieur le ministre où
est l'état qu'est devenue l'autorité de
l'état
pour vous répondre la parole et
communistes de l'intérieur ainsi vous
serez prêt non mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur je ne
partage pas votre vision
même si les faits que vous évoquez
notamment pour votre collègue sénatrice
sont totalement insupportable
inacceptable et j'ai demandé au préfet
de prendre langue avec elle pour que
tous les moyens soient mis évidemment
pour garantir sa liberté d'expression sa
liberté de dire et de combattre comme le
souhaite comme elle le veut non pas
seulement parce qu'elle est sénatrice et
ce serait déjà une excellente raison
mais tout simplement parce que dans ce
pays nous devons garantir cette liberté
d'expression mais je ne veux pas vous
laisser dire que les voyous pourrait
aujourd'hui tenir la dragée haute face à
notre police où notre journal marie
chaque jour chaque nuit
chaque fois que la police est appelée
elle vient chaque fois elle intervient
on a beaucoup parlé ces derniers jours
et hélas depuis de longues années de la
question des violences urbaines comme
vous je les dénonce
mais je fais en sorte que la police soit
renforcée j'évoquais tout à l'heure la
politique de 10000 recrutements
nécessaires pour que nous soyons
présents partout y compris dans les
quartiers et nous sommes présents
partout y compris dans les quartiers
nana lisons pas les événements
médiatiques comme une ligne une tendance
en matière de violences urbaines si on
regarde par rapport à l'an dernier nous
sommes sur une constante y compris
d'ailleurs pendant la période du
confinement à l'exception de
l'ile-de-france où nous avons connu une
augmentation significative mais ça
n'était pas le cas sur l'ensemble du
territoire national mais à chaque fois
police et gendarmerie malgré le risque
de guet-apens il y en a eu 120 ont été
identifiées pendant la période du conte
du confinement comme étant des
guets-apens à chaque fois police et
gendarmerie sont intervenus et je ne
pourrai pas vous laisser penser qu' il
n'ya pas d'interpellation au contraire
des interpellations il y en a eu plus de
300 individus pendant la seule période
du confinement ont été interpellées dans
le cadre de ces violences urbaines des
condamnations ont déjà eu lieu des
condamnations à la prison ferme des
condamnations avec dépôt immédiat et
écrous immédiat voilà la réalité mais il
n'empêche que c'est un combat que nous
devons mener pas seulement monsieur le
sénateur par l'interpellation mais aussi
par la prévention par la présence et je
ne souhaite pas opposer la nécessité
d'avoir une police de sécurité du
quotidien qui s'appuie sur le travail
des élus
pour porter une ambition pour les
quartiers les plus difficiles de notre
pays et une légitime répression les deux
doivent aller de pair
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue jean françois longeot pour le
groupe de l'union centriste merci me
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues et ma question s'adressait
bruno le maire -ministre de l'économie
et des finances question pour laquelle
je tiens à associer pleinement ma
collègue valérie létard ici présentes
dans les tribunes ainsi que notre
collègue jacques le nay monsieur le
ministre vous aviez vous avez signé hier
le prêt garanti par l'état 2 5 milliards
d'euros pour aider le groupe renault en
grande difficulté grande difficulté déjà
avant la crise du coc vie de 19 à cette
occasion vous avez rappelé les garanties
sociales associées aux dits prêts tels
que le maintien de l'emploi et de
l'activité industrielle sur le site de
maubeuge au delà de 2023
ces garanties sont rassurants ce mais
nous serons très vigilants à ce que le
rendez-vous d'étape fixé dans six mois
ne remettent pas en cause les digues
garanties que nous estimons
consubstantiel d'un tel soutien public
massif car ce prix intervient pourtant
quatre jours à peine après l'annoncé
d'un plan de restructuration et la
suppression de 4600 emplois en france
pour un fleuron industriel national
monsieur le ministre ce prêt intervient
également sept jours après la
présentation d'un plan de soutien massif
à l'industrie automobile qui devait être
la rampe de lancement d'une souveraineté
économique retrouvée ce plan et plus
globalement la stratégie de l'état
actionnaire
par bien d'autres il au pire à empêcher
la désindustrialisation hexagonale ou au
mieux à permettre la relance gallimard
localisation dans notre pays d'une
partie de la production
et si oui laquelle enfin entre un plan
de soutien à l'automobile qui se veut
être un véritable pâques et avec ce
nouveau prêt quelle garantie l'état
actionnaire at il obtenu de ses
engagements financiers en termes
d'emploi en termes d'aménagement du
territoire en terme de traitement des
sous traitants et en vision stratégique
d'avenir
je vous remercie pour me répondre la
parole et à madame la secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'économie et des
finances vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés mais monsieur le
député longeau monsieur avec ça arrive
un jour monsieur le sénateur longeau
renault perd de l'argent
vous le savez vous l'avez dit ses
capacités de production en france sont
d'un million de voitures un peu plus
cette année elle en produira à peu près
600 milles ce qui veut dire que l est en
surcapacité massive
ce n'est pas de votre faute ce n'est pas
de la mienne c'est le fait que entre le
co vide et une course aux volumes
renault n'a aujourd'hui pas les moyens
ou une infrastructure industrielle qui
est beaucoup trop importante par rapport
à la réalité des clients dont elle
dispose plus largement renault joue sa
survie et l'industrie automobile joue
également une partie difficile c'est
probablement la crise la plus difficile
de toute son histoire
huit cent mille emplois en france 400
milles dans l'industrie 400 milles dans
les services et c'est ce qui justifie de
prendre ce plan automobile qui est un
plan automobile à la hauteur des enjeux
un plan automobile qui ne vise pas
seulement à sauver les meubles en
donnant des soutiens à des entreprises
en difficulté mais qui vise justement à
construire l'avenir construire l'avenir
c'est définir positionner renault est
positionné l'automobile française parmi
les leaders en matière de véhicules
électriques de véhicules autonomes
cela signifie accompagner la transition
de ces entreprises vous parliez des sous
traitants nous demandons à renault nous
demandons un peugeot
nous demandons également aux sous
traitants de rang 1 d'accompagner la
transformation industrielle des sous
traitants de rang 2 de rang 3 cpme ces
deux pays qui sont implantées dans nos
territoires
voilà une première réponse deuxième
réponse quelles sont les contreparties
ses contreparties au delà de celles que
j'ai mentionnés pour les sous traitants
c'est plus d'un milliard d'euros
d'investissements pour relocaliser des
productions
en france de renault et de peugeot de
faurecia de plastic omnium et de valeo
là des faits concrets nous allons
continuer à travailler aux côtés de la
filière car ça va être une bataille de
tous les instants
mais au cours sous la maison bien nous
arriverons à maintenir notre présence
industrielle dans l'automobile au plus
haut niveau
selon joe si vous avez quelques secondes
et bien compris votre votre réponse mais
effectivement préparer l'avenir ça veut
dire le faire et je pense que sur la
politique environnementale que l'on doit
mener
on doit aujourd'hui préparer demain
c'est à dire en exemple le recyclage des
batteries et c'est très important que
nous soyons leader et que nous soyons
encore pas attendre les autres pays pour
effectivement recyclés nos batteries
merci la parole est maintenant président
thani mohamed soilihi et pour le groupe
de la république en marche monsieur le
président merci monsieur le président
mais c'est le premier ministre mesdames
et messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
monsieur le ministre de la santé je me
fais ici la voix de mon collègue antoine
karam le 28 mai dernier vous même et le
premier ministre avait présenté la carte
de la seconde phase de confinement si
presque toute la france est passé au
vert
mayotte et la guyane sont avec l'île de
france désormais classé au niveau de
vigilance orange mayotte et le
territoire d'outre-mer le plus touché
par le coc u19 plus de 1993 sky sont
identifiés et 24 décès sont à déplorer
en guyane le virus s'est également
considérablement propager ces dernières
semaines pour atteindre 5 117 cas
positifs dont un décès vous le savez
cette progression de l'épidémie n'est
pas sans lien avec l'inquiétante
situation sanitaire de son voisin
brésilien l'état d'amapa à lui seul
compte en effet près de 9000 900 cas
positifs de 128 décès et un système de
santé totalement saturé le virus ne
s'embarrassant pas des frontières les
communes de saint georges de l'oyapock
et de camopi sont rapidement devenus les
deux premiers cluster de guyane en
réponse la mobilisation récente de la
réserve sanitaire est venu renforcer une
campagne massive de tests déployés dans
l'est lyonnais qui reste cependant
limitée aux seuls français à mayotte ces
actions
rapidement mises en place commencent à
porter leurs fruits et hormis le cluster
importants découverts récemment à la
maison d'arrêt de majicavo la situation
semble se stabiliser mais en guyane
considérant la porosité de la frontière
nous pouvons nous interroger sur
l'efficience de mesures qui se
limiterait à la seule rive française de
l'oyapock
il en va de la protection de la
population de l'est guyane et bien
entendu mais pas simplement puisque la
circulation du virus s'intensifie dans
l'ensemble du territoire aussi pouvez
vous nous dire comment le gouvernement
entend faire évoluer la stratégie
sanitaire en guyane au regard de la
poussée de l'épidémie au brésil un
dispositif de coordination et de
mutualisation des moyens
ne pourrait-il pas être mis en oeuvre
dans le cadre de la coopération
transfrontalière
merci pour vous répondre la parole et au
ministre des solidarités de la chanter
monsieur verrons monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur soit soilih je vous
remercie pour votre question qui fait
écho à l'inquiétude des habitants et des
élus vous traiter de la situation en
guyane qui effectivement particulière en
france du fait de la frontière avec le
brésil
et vous l'avez dit vous-même la
situation sanitaire au brésil est
inquiétante évolutive en guyane il ya
désormais plus de 500 cas même si vous
avez raison il ya peu de cas graves
encore à ce stade et c'est heureux vous
m'interrogez à juste titre sur les
moyens mis en place pour lutter
efficacement contre l'épidémie sachez
d'abord qu'il y ait des moyens humains à
travers la réserve sanitaire sur saint
georges
il est une équipe de douze réservistes
qui vont être relayée à partir de la
semaine prochaine à camopi une autre
équipe de douze réserviste est capable
d'agir y compris sur l'ensemble du
fleuve oyapock une équipe d'une
vingtaine de réserviste est en train
d'être déployés du côté de cayenne et
est capable d'être extrêmement réactif
pour bouger partout il y aurait des cas
qui se feraient jour et notamment le
long du fleuve maroni
il y as au delà des dispositifs humains
des renforts qui sont apportées à
certains établissements c'est le cas à
iracoubo pour protéger l'ouest de la
guyane qui est encore bien épargné par
épidémie et c'est heureux il y un appui
au ch de cayenne où l'épidémie de dengue
a conduit à l'absence d'un certain
nombre de soignants et qu'il fallait
pouvoir relayer en termes de moyens
techniques la politique de tests a pris
de l'ampleur d'abord grâce au fret
sanitaire qui a permis d'apporter des
moyens nécessaires pour tester la rs et
très mobilisés ainsi que la préfecture
et santé publique france est désormais
des laboratoires trois laboratoires en
guyane en ont développé des drive pour
augmenter cette politique de test
j'ajoute qu'il ya également d'autres
renforts matériels avec par exemple 13
respirateur qui sont arrivés ou en train
d'arriver au ch de cayenne pour pouvoir
renforcer les capacités d'accueil pour
des patients plus sévères les capacités
d'isolement des malades ont été
augmentés plus d'une centaine de
patients sont désormais hébergés à leur
demande dans un hôtel et enfin nous
agissons également en solidarité en
coopération avec nos voisins brésiliens
notamment l'hôpital brésilien de yap kok
qui a bénéficié de matériel de
protection sanitaire
merci la parole est à notre collègue luc
sorry pour le groupe l'est républicain
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues lorsqu'un ministre se déplace
les moyens de la république c'est à dire
les moyens qu'ils appartiennent à la
nation tout entière sont mis à sa
disposition et devrait dans ces
conditions se faire un devoir de laisser
de côté toute attitude qui conduirait à
privilégier les représentants d'une
chambre plus qu'une autre
ou pire à faire en sorte que sa famille
politique soit favorisé alors que les
déplacements se multiplient les
modalités de l'organisation de ceux ci
laissent désormais ce sont jeunes ainsi
les préfets précise par écrit que
dorénavant compte tenu des conditions
sanitaires et du maintien des gestes
barrières
il avait été fait le choix qu un député
représentera l'ensemble des
parlementaires députés et sénateurs
toutes tendances politiques confondues
c'est pour le moins restrictif et le
hasard faisant bien les choses
il semblerait que très majoritairement
les circonscriptions concernées par ces
visites ministérielles soit celle
détenue par les députés de la république
en marche ou de votre majorité
madame le ministre cette situation je l'
ai personnellement vécu lors de la
visite de messieurs riester et le moine
venu à orléans pour rencontrer les
professionnels de la culture et de
tourisme est à nouveau lors d'une visite
ministérielle ce matin même à la base
aérienne de bricy évincer la
représentation nationale n'est pas
propre à mon département
mes collègues de saône-et-loire des
yvelines de haute garonne de l'oise et
d'autres départements ont ces derniers
jours vécu exactement la même situation
ils sont devenus persona non grata leur
présence républicaine n'étant pas la
bienvenue
mon collègue du doubs a même été
congédié par le préfet d'une
manifestation patriotique
la dérive est donc nationale et
l'initiative ne peut plus être celle
d'un préfet et les s'agit-il alors d'une
instruction gouvernementale qui viserait
écarter les sénateurs et surtout aucun
parti ne peut être la république à lui
seul pensez vous madame la ministre
qu'il est légitime de privilégier les
députés la plupart du temps de votre
majorité jusqu'à décider qu'à eux seuls
ils représentent toutes sensibilités et
qui à eux seuls ils représentent à la
fois l'assemblée nationale et le sénat
je remercie
[Applaudissements]
auprès du premier ministre porte-parole
du gouvernement vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur merci pour votre
question qui va me permettre d'éclaircir
les choses en matière de déplacements de
membres du gouvernement
je crois qu'il faut distinguer deux
périodes la première période a été celle
du confinement
durant cette période les déplacements
ministériels ont été évidemment réduit
au strict nécessaire vous l'avez sans
doute vous même constaté et nous avons
eu effectivement des consignes
nationales permettant de réduire à la
fois au maximum les délégations
ministérielles mais également les
délégations qui pouvait accueillir les
ministres sur place à l'exception
parfois d'élus dont la fonction par
exemple siéger au conseil
d'administration d'un établissement
rendait obligatoire leur présence au
cours du déplacement
cela se comprend aisément compte tenu de
la situation particulière que nous
vivions depuis le 11 mai cette situation
particulière malgré tout perdure même si
les conditions sanitaires ont été
améliorées au fur et à mesure du temps
au fond depuis le 11 mai c'est
l'intelligence collective qui doit
dominer nous devons nous imposer en tant
que ministre les mêmes conditions que
celles qui sont imposées en matière
sanitaire à l'ensemble des français
la distanciation physique le respect des
gestes barrières il y a donc à chaque
déplacement ministériel
un regard qui est posé sur la nature du
déplacement les endroits où ce
déplacement a lieu est ce que c'est à
l'intérieur ex que c'est à l'extérieur
est-ce qu'il ya matière à pouvoir avoir
un grand nombre de personnes autour du
ministre l'application stricte des
mesures barrières des gestes de
distanciation et des gestes des gestes
barrière doit être notre priorité pour
que ces déplacements ministériels puisse
se dérouler dans de bonnes causes
je conçois aisément monsieur le sénateur
qu'il soit parfois difficile de
comprendre ces situations qu'il puisse y
avoir des frustrations de
l'incompréhension mais je crois qu'il ne
faut pas y voir absolument aucune malice
politique ni aucun prix village qu'ils
soient adressés à qui que ce soit et je
m'étonne que dans une enceinte et
démocratique
d'aucuns estiment qu'il s'agit de
quitter la salle les préfets pour
clôturer on l'intervention font
évidemment oeuvre de discernement ils
appliquent le décret du 13 décembre du
13 septembre 1981 au plus haut motore
money public et les préséances pour
déterminer qui doit être présent avec un
objectif évidemment donc les boucles et
les gestes barrière je vous remercie
la parole est à madame martine filière
pour le groupe socialiste et républicain
de la parole merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre je m'exprime ici au
nom du groupe socialiste et plus
particulièrement nom de mes collègues de
seine maritime et du val de marne
l'état a garanti un prêt de 5 milliards
d'euros à renault tandis que 8 annoncé
un plan d'économies avec 4600
suppressions de postes en france et la
restructuration de six usines
nous nous félicitons que la colère des
salariés de maubeuge et la mobilisation
de tous les élus du territoire avec qui
j'étais samedi étaient entendues et des
garanties et été apportées néanmoins
nous restons vigilants
d'autant plus que d'autres sites sont
toujours en sursis
adia pile il n'y a aucune garantie de la
pérennité de l'usiné alpine à
choisy-le-roi la fermeture de ce modèle
d'économie circulaire est une aberration
sans compter la cession de la fonderie
de bretagne à caudan les craintes à
cléon et à sandouville
nous ne pouvons nous en satisfaire et
nous continuons de demander des
contreparties en dise yeuse socialement
avec le maintien de tous les emplois et
de tous les sites les re localisation de
et le permettre il faut en effet rompre
avec trente ans de délocalisation mais
nous avons aussi besoin d'un état qui
favorise un large investissement
insuffle une stratégie pour la filière
automobile et la réindustrialisation du
pays en accélérant la recherche
développement pour favoriser
l'innovation au service de l'écologie
l'industrie et l'industrie automobile
doivent se verdir pour respecter les
accords de paris et l'engagement de
mettre fin à la vente de véhicules
thermiques aussi madame la ministre
l'état actionnaire majoritaire de
renault vaty actionnaire majoritaire de
renault va t'il imposer des exigences
écologiques les aides publiques aux
entreprises seront elles enfin codis
conditionné au respect des critères
sociaux et environnementaux
on vous répond de la parole et de
l'inspecteur d'état ont fait que les
mondialistes de l'économie réclame pas
dire une hache et la parole merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice il le plan
automobile annoncé par le président de
la république répond je crois très
directement à vos préoccupations que je
partage effectivement l'avenir de la
filière autonomie automobile c'est le
verdissement et l'innovation et c'est
pour ces raisons que ce plan qui
représente 8 milliards d'euros 8
milliards d'euros investis dans cette
dans ce verdissement de l'industrie
automobile avec le la patrie le projet
de batterie électrique européen auquel
renault va participer avec des aides
pour accompagner les français dans le
changement de leur véhicule pour leur
permettre d'acheter des véhicules moins
polluants
non seulement les plus modestes mais
pour nous tous la capacité à accéder aux
véhicules électriques aux véhicules
hybrides rechargeables qui apporte un
bénéfice en termes de d'émissions de co2
c est là vont dans le bon sens et vont
dans le sens du verdissement
ce sont aussi des soutiens importants à
l'innovation que nous avons mis en place
et je veux souligner l'effort notamment
d'accompagnement des projets de
véhicules à hydrogène qui seront
accompagnés dans ce cadre c'est
également de manière plus générale
le soutien à l'innovation les nouvelles
la voiture de demain c'est non seulement
le véhicule vert mais c'est aussi le
véhicule autonome et il est important
que la france construisent une
souveraineté en la matière tant on
connaît le retard de l'europe et de la
france en matière de gestion des data et
de grandes plateformes numériques
ce virage là ce virage de l'industrie du
numérique ou du numérique appliquée à
l'industrie nous ne devons pas le rater
enfin évidemment un des grands éléments
du plan ce les relocalisations et le
capital humain les relocalisations
nous avons des engagements je les ai
site est tout à l'heure un milliard
d'investissements la relocalisation de
véhicules électriques ou de chaînes de
traction électriques en france et donc
c'est tout ce plan que nous allons
déployer maintenant pour que notre
industrie automobile soit au niveau des
défis qui l'attendent
merci la parole le pr collègues sonia de
la provôté pour le groupe de l'union
centriste avait la parole monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues j'associe pleinement à cette
question ma collègue nadia ce logo la
tempête covin 19 à peine par ces
hôpitaux et cliniques doivent désormais
reprendre leurs activités nombreux sont
les malades qui ont dû attendre dans ce
contexte est paru un décret le 23 avril
dernier visant à réquisitionner cinq
produits anesthésie en pénurie
depuis la situation sur le terrain est
illisible les pharmacies hospitalières
ne peuvent plus les commander car l'état
en détient désormais le monopole d'achat
et de livraison
la gestion au local se faisant via les
ars le but était de prioriser les
établissements les plus touchés par
l'épidémie
les taux faibles d'approvisionnement
imposé aux créer de très fortes tensions
dans les territoires ces dernières
semaines nombreux sont les
établissements de soins suffisamment
livre est pas mal d'intervention ou dû
être décalé certains hôpitaux sont
rationnées d'autres sont livrés mais
sans que l'on sache comment la
répartition est faite des alternatives
dégradé de prise en charge sont mises en
place
c'est un réel recul avec des risques
pour les patients une nouvelle crise
sanitaire se profile la situation est
urgente dans certains départements les
pharmaciens hospitaliers en lien direct
avec les besoins sont dans un carcan qui
ne permet ni la réactivité ni la
souplesse nécessaire pour ne pas dire
vital faute de transparence et de
dialogue sur la gestion les disparités
se creuse l'équité face aux soins est
mise à mal
même la perspective d'une éventuelle
selon vague une seconde vannes ne
saurait justifier cette situation
monsieur le ministre le stock national
est-il reconstitués comme cela semble
logique
quelles sont les clés de répartition
actuelle qui créent les disparités
délétère sur le terrain les besoins de
teyran pour des patients haute que kovy
des temps réel
qu'en pensez-vous cesser le
contingentement actuelle et redonner la
main aux acteurs de terrain dans les
établissements de santé pour vous
répondre la parole est oubliée des
solidarités me sentais je suivais rang
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice sonia de la provôté merci pour
votre question que je comprends et je
sais qu'il y a de l'émoi et des
questionnements sur l'ensemble du
territoire de la part de nombreux
médecins de quoi parlons nous nous
parlons et nous l'avons déjà dit
plusieurs fois que le premier ministre
au cours des dernières semaines la
consommation de certains médicaments
anesthésiques a augmenté elle a explosé
de 2000% elle reste encore très élevé
dans certaines régions du monde
notamment le brésil j'en ai parlé tout à
l'heure aux états unis où l'épidémie
fait rage et les consommations de
médicaments de réanimation sont
priorisés par les grands laboratoires
internationaux ce qu'on peut comprendre
pour pouvoir sauver des vies nous
mettons tout en oeuvre
semaine après semaine jour après jour
croyez moi pour reconstituer un stock
national nous permettant non seulement
de voir loin dans l'hypothèse où il y
aurait une augmentation de l'épidémie
mais également pour permettre aux
patients de bénéficier de chirurgie
règle est programmée comme c'est le cas
habituellement sur notre territoire un
médicament un médicament pose beaucoup
de problèmes le propofol propofol croyez
moi on ne peut pas le fabriquer comme ça
même les matières premières sont très
rares à l'échelle mondiale
tous les pays font face à cette pénurie
extrêmement et qui complexifie
énormément les choses et je remercie
d'ailleurs beaucoup les chirurgiens qui
sont obligés de freiner encore une
partie de l'europe reprise d'activité je
sais qu'il ya des disparités
territoriales la réquisition c'est pas
franchement de réquisition ce de
gestion nationale du stock et des
commandes de manière un à sécuriser les
commandes à l'international vis-à-vis de
très gros laboratoires qui ont des
demandes qui explose de partout sur la
sur la planète et ensuite d'être capable
d'avoir quand même une gestion
rigoureuse de ses stocks de manière à re
tu es notre capacité nationale de
réponses si jamais il y avait à nouveau
un afflux de malades en réanimation et
en même temps d'être capables à chaque
établissement d'assurer tout ou partie
de son activité chirurgicale
je vous le dis madame la sénatrice hélas
hélas en matière de propofol
la situation ne reviendra pas à la
normale avant plusieurs semaines
il faudra attendre cet été pour pouvoir
reprendre une activité de chirurgie
programmée à 100%
néanmoins tout ce qui est locorégionale
tout ce qui est chirurgien d'urgence
tout ce qui est chirurgie carcinologique
évidemment se poursuit elle n'a jamais
été d'ailleurs suspendu y compris
pendant la période épidémique mais
croyez-moi nous mettons tout en oeuvre
pour sécuriser les commandes en importer
massivement et cela rejoint à nouveau
les problématiques que nous avons déjà
abordé dans cette enceinte qui est
l'autonomie de la france et de l'europe
vis-à-vis de médicaments absolument
indispensable absolument vitaux nous
n'avons pas reproduire les erreurs du
passé
merci madame de la prévôté ou d'y
ajouter quelques jours oui monsieur le
ministre de problème c'est quand même de
redonner de l'autonomie aux terrains
parce qu'il ya une inadéquation entre
l'architecturé la décision nationale la
façon on s'est réparti
il y à une absence de transparence quand
même pour bon nombre d'acteurs de
terrain
enfin en tout cas c'est vécu comme tel
et la réparer la répartition est
inégalitaire
donc il faut au moins que les choses se
fassent de la bonne façon de façon
claire équilibré qu'il n'y ait pas de
perte de chance d'un territoire à
l'autre
et puis en plein figure de la santé se
poser la question quand même de
l'administration centrale hospitalière
et régionale de la santé peut être
d'être donné
sa force et son pouvoir aux acteurs de
terrain dans le domaine de la santé
journée c'est aussi la parole et à
d'autres collègues
chris emerson pour la réunion
administrative des sénateurs de figurant
sur la liste
d'aucuns gros vous avez la parole mes
chers collègues merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre la crise
sanitaire a mis en évidence la pénurie
de certains médicaments essentiels ainsi
que les failles de notre système
d'approvisionnement
le problème n'est pas nouveau puisque
80% de la fabrication des molécules de
médicaments est aujourd'hui délocaliser
les sacs de nombreux traitements
dépendent de réseaux de distribution
internationaux et certains d'entre eux
notamment des génériques sont fabriqués
uniquement en inde ou en chine
cette dépendance sur des produits aussi
stratégique est d'autant plus
inquiétante que nous n'avons pas des
chaînes de production nécessaires dans
nos
pays nous savons que la relocalisation
est un processus long et complexe
toutefois il serait possible d'envisager
un rapatriement progressif sur le
territoire français et européens
la fabrication de molécules majeurs
comme par exemple celles qui sont
utilisées dans le traitement du cancer
ou d'une longue maladie doit faire
partie des priorités
tout comme la production de médicaments
génériques aujourd'hui sous traiter à
100% qu'ils devraient au moins en partie
revenir sur le sol français
n'oublions pas que cette pénurie a créé
de graves tensions dans la prise en
charge des maladies du coc vide
en mars dernier les hôpitaux européens
dont les hôpitaux de paris ont alerté
les pouvoirs publics sur le manque de
médicaments essentiels pour les unités
de soins intensifs et de réanimation ce
type dallaire doit impérativement être
prises au sérieux pour éviter de
reproduire les mêmes erreurs
je souhaite je souhaite donc ça
connaître madame la ministre vous
attention sur ce sujet et savoir si le
gouvernement a déjà entrepris les
démarches concernant la reco la lie la
relocalisation de la production sur
notre territoire et au niveau européen
on répondre la parole et à madame la
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'économie
vous avez la parole merci beaucoup
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice herzog
merci de souligner effectivement à la la
ça va pas du tout merci merci de
souligner effectivement qu'il n'est pas
si facile que ça de réimplanter de
relocaliser des industries
pharmaceutiques en france et en europe
et c'est bien la situation que nous
avons trouvé et c'est bien pour cela que
nous avons confié
il ya quelques mois c'était avant le
convive 19 un rapport une mission à
monsieur bio pour justement faire le
point sur les pénuries de médicaments et
voir quelle doit être notre stratégie
pour réimplanter des sites de production
en france mais également en europe car
je crois que sur ce sujet là il faut
avoir une approche européenne est
aujourd'hui locaux vides 19 d'oran sens
dans cette dans cette appréciation mais
elle renforce aussi la conviction de nos
homologues européens qui étaient
peut-être un peu moins interventionniste
en la matière vous avez raison il faut
relocaliser des productions de principes
de base en france et en europe de
manière à éviter d'être dépendant d'un
seul pays
pourquoi pour éviter que une crise
géopolitique une crise sanitaire une
crise climatique ou autres blocs
l'approvisionnement et en toute matière
il vaut mieux avoir un double
approvisionnements et un
approvisionnement de proximité on a vu
aussi la crise d'une logistique qui
arrête de fonctionner la deuxième chose
c'est que nous allons travailler aussi
sur une politique du médicament qui
évolue je crois que olivier vers en
partage cette vision que l'industrie et
la santé doivent travailler main dans la
main pour prévoir dans notre politique
du prix des médicaments
le fait de pouvoir réimplanter des sites
en france et quelque part d'anticiper le
coût de production français et puis nous
allons également travailler pour au
niveau européen lancé un eeepc hui c'est
à dire ces programmes qui nous
permettent de soutenir massivement un
secteur nous l'avons fait pour la
batterie électrique
nous l'avons fait pour la
microélectronique faisons le pour la
santé je crois que mes homologues
autrichiens et allemands sont
parfaitement en phase il ne reste plus
qu'à travailler rapidement
[Applaudissements]
madame la ministre depuis plusieurs
années des médicaments pour le
traitement des maladies graves se sont
retrouvés en rupture de stock
ces pénuries faut courir d'importants
risques aux malades mais également à
notre pays c'est monsieur le premier
ministre
dames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues vraiment terminé
avec les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement les prochaines auront lieu
le mercredi 10 juin 2020 je vais
maintenant suspendre la séance je vous
rappelle les consignes sanitaires
elle sera reprise cette séance à 16h15
pour un débat du sur le thème quelles
nouvelles politiques publiques à
destination de la jeunesse afin d'aider
ces publics particulièrement exposées
dans la prise en charge des conséquences
économiques et sociales de la crise
sanitaire actuelle à la demande du
groupe socialiste et républicain
la séance est suspendue elle reprendra à
16h15 voilà pour cette séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
une séance mouvementée vous l'avez vu
elle a été marqué notamment par le
départ de l'hémicycle des sénateurs du
groupe
lr le groupe henner qui a quitté
l'hémicycle pour protester contre la
manière dont les visites ministérielles
sont organisés cela faisait l'objet
d'une question et c'est la réponse de la
porte parole du gouvernement si bête
ndiaye qui a suscité leur colère je suis
avec le président du groupe plr au sénat
bruno retailleau
que s'est il passé exactement tout
simplement donc c'était une question que
posait un de nos collègues luxe rime qui
s'étonnait que les moyens de l'état
étaient confisqués instrumentalisée au
profit de en marche puisque on a
constaté depuis le confinement depuis
plusieurs semaines que les préfets ont
sans doute des consignes ce ne sont pas
eux les responsables
mais quand il y à une visite
ministérielle sont invités un
parlementaire en général en marche
députés en marche et il est dit aux
autres parlementaires qui sont d'un
autre bord par exemple des sénateurs et
l'air ou même des sénateurs ps qu' ils
seront représentés par ce député en
marche
voilà et c'est que ces cas là se sont
multipliés c'est pas un département c2
c3 c'est plus de dix départements donc
nous on estimait que nous devions posée
au premier ministre cette question est
ce que en france dans une république
peut-on privatiser peut-on
instrumentaliser les moyens de l'état au
profit d'un seul parti je ne le crois
pas
selon uniterre vous a répondu si bête
n'diaye la porte et malheureusement ce
n'est pas un argument que vous entendez
franchement franchement elle nous a
répondu qu'il s'agissait d'observer
des mesures barrières je veux bien
croire qu' on puisse réduire les
assemblées mais à ce moment là on fait
un tirage au sort
je pense que le confinement je pense que
la crise sanitaire
c'est un beau prétexte elle a bon dos en
réalité ce qui se cache derrière c'est
une volonté d'imposer sur chaque visite
ministérielle de mettre en avant un
parlementaire en général un député en
marche au détriment de toutes les autres
sensibilités
voilà je pense qu'on est une république
nous sommes une démocratie et l'état n'a
pas être confisqué de cette façon lors
de visites ministérielles ça ça ne doit
pas être le nouveau monde sait que je
change et que les parlementaires de
l'opposition joue également bon je les
mets en kalalu lille je ne demande pas
la lune
je demande que les sensibilités soient
respectés je demande que les moyens de
l'état ne soit pas confisqué au profit
d'un seul parti c'est tout c'est une
demande qui républicaine
c'est une demande qui est sereine
paisible mais j'entends que lorsqu'on
pose des questions la porte parole du
gouvernement ou peu importe un autre
ministre ne nous répondent pas aussi
légèrement
comment peut-on dire aux français que
les députés seuls l hérault m soit
invitée que les autres députés ou
sénateurs soit écarté tout simplement
pour respecter les gestes barrière
franchement c'est se fiche de la tête
des gens on préfère se met le
gouvernement se moque de vous dans ce
contexte mais bien sûr c'est est
injustifiable
c'est injustifiable et c'est parce que
nous avions une réponse qui se moquer de
nous que nous avons quitté l'hémicycle
c'est très très rare vous savez au sénat
je pense que au delà de nous au delà de
notre groupe politique c'est la
république qui est en jeu aucun
gouvernement aucune sensibilité
politique ne peut prétendre s'arroger le
droit de représenter la france
la démocratie française la république
française à lui seul ce n'est pas
possible
bruno retailleau justement l'actualité
il y avait bien d'autres sujets à
évoquer aussi aujourd'hui mais je
voudrais tout de même votre réaction à
ces manifestations qui ont eu lieu hier
à l'appel du comité de soutien à la
famille d'adama traoré qui fait le
parallèle entre la mort de john floyd
aux états unis et celle d'un adama
traoré
moi je pense que c'est très dangereux
qu'une famille ressent douloureusement
la perte de l'un des siens je le
comprends parfaitement mais une
souffrance ne peut pas être là aussi
retourner contre la société
on ne peut pas faire d' équivalent entre
ce qui s'est passé aux états unis et ce
qui s'est passé en france
certains cherchent à utiliser le drame
des états unis pour leur tournée contre
la république et surtout contre nos
policiers et nos gendarmes contre celles
et ceux qui ont pour fonction d'être le
bouclier en réalité des français et je
pense qu'il faut se méfier d'un modèle
américain qu'est le modèle
communautarisme le modèle
communautariste c'est celui qui
racialise qui renvoie chacun à sa race à
ses origines à sa religion nous c'est le
modèle républicain
on est français pas parce qu'on a une
couleur de peau particulière part parce
qu'on professe une religion particulière
blême là en france mais bien sûr mais
mais ne disons pas que les gendarmes ou
les policiers sont rongés ces deux corps
sont rangés par le raciste c'est
absolument faux penser que la justice
française laisserait passer de tels
actes c'est aussi mal connaître la
justice française donc gardons raison et
je vois bien que derrière cela il ya
ceux qui veulent organiser la
convergence des luttes
on l'a déjà vu au moment dé gilet jaune
y compris avec ceux et celles qui
prétendent soutenir cette cause en
détournant justement cette mort
vraisemblablement accidentelle donc je
pense que c'est inacceptable et ça ne
peut être que des ferments de violences
en france donc je crois qu'il faut
raison garder il faut prendre du recul
de la hauteur
eh bien merci beaucoup renault
retailleau d'avoir répondu à mes
questions et tout de suite je vous
propose de revenir à ce temps fort tout
à l'heure dans l'hémicycle lors de cette
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement cette réponse de la porte
parole du gouvernement si bête ndiaye
qui a donc suscité et bien ce départ du
groupe et l'air écouté par les préfets
clôturer mon intervention font
évidemment oeuvre de discernement ils
appliquent le décret du 13 décembre du
transept en 1991 lui remet money public
et les précédentes pour déterminer qui
doit être présent avec un objectif
évidemment dont les gestes barrière je
vous remercie
la parole est à madame martine filleul
pour le groupe socialiste et républicain
vous avez la parole voilà pour cette
image forte qui a marqué tout à l'heure
et bien cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
un espagnol nash et bonjour merci
beaucoup de répondre à mes questions
tout d'abord votre votre réaction à ce
qu'il s'est passé tout à l'heure ce
départ du groupe bel air qui estime que
finalement les moyens de l'état de la
république sont confisqués lors de ses
visites ministérielles et qui ne
comprennent pas que des parlementaires
de l'opposition n'y sois pas invitée
alors on va être très simple on est au
milieu d'une crise sanitaire qui est
très grave
on est au milieu d'une crise économique
qui est très grave et ça ça paraît pas
du tout au niveau des attentes des
français
moi j'ai fait des déplacements
ministériels je les compte sur les
doigts d'une main
parce qu'à cause de cette crise
sanitaire on en fait très très peu et
effectivement ils sont organisés de
manière très resserrée et un coup c'est
quelqu'un de l'opposition un coup c'est
pas quelqu'un de l'opposition et lorsque
c'est d'être réputé il se trouve vous
dites que ce n'est qu'en cordes
reviendra que la république en marche
mais il demande enfin je crois que c'est
vraiment un peu de politique
politicienne et ça n'a pas sa place dans
le moment du dans ce moment par an sera
bien on se rappelle qu' il y avait eu un
cette question qui a été posée lors de
la visite des manuels macron dans le
nord
justement autour et bien deux des sites
de renault et de la situation de renault
xavier bertrand notamment avaient
protesté parce qu'ils n'avaient pas été
invités
mais ce qui est important c'est que les
réunions de décision se fasse avec les
élus et bruno le maire était encore hier
avec xavier bertrand avec tous les élus
du territoire du nord pour parler du cas
de maubeuge ça ce sont des réunions de
travail ce sont des réunions qui
d'ailleurs donne lieu à une
communication on ne les cache pas donc
je crois qu'il faut être très
décontracté sur ces sujets là
l'important c'est de travailler ensemble
et vraiment je ne suis pas sûr qu'on ait
besoin de ce type de petite polémique
qui nourrit l'anecdote
mais ne permettent pas de placer notre
esprit notre temps là où c'est important
c'est à dire faire face à cette crise
justement on va parler bien du fond de
la question de la crise de renault vous
avez été questionné à plusieurs fois sur
ce sujet lors de cette séance de
questions d'actualité
certains sénateurs disent que l'argent
public accompagne des suppressions
d'emplois même si ce ne sont pas des
licenciements secs vous l'avez dit est
ce que vous comprenez que ça cela choque
certains côtés moi je suis dans une
génération d'une génération qui a vu
partir des pans entiers de l'industrie
qui a vu partir la sidérurgie qui a vu
partir le textile
au début on dit que ça va tenir et après
on ne fait rien et on n'accompagne pas
parce que la compétitivité mondiale est
ce qu'elle est renault est en difficulté
moi je ne suis pas dans le déni
je sais que renault est en difficulté et
je ne le cache pas il est salarié le
comprennent d'ailleurs est donc
aujourd'hui ce qui est en jeu c'est de
sauver renault et pas seulement de le
sauver en mettant de l'argent public
c'est de sauver renault pour qu elles
puissent construire sa trajectoire
future réserve qu'elle soit au rendez
vous demain qu'elle puisse se
transformer et aller vers les moteurs et
les voitures les plus écologiques vers
les voitures les plus modernes
c'est ça que nous faisons aujourd'hui et
le travail que nous menons avec les
organisations syndicales nous ne les
avons réunis hier sur le site de
maubeuge
nous les avons vu la semaine dernière au
niveau des équipes pour partager la
situation ce travail de dialogue social
exemplaire nous devons continuer à le
mener mais ne nous trompons pas de
combat aujourd'hui l'enjeu pour renault
c'est un enjeu de baisse massive des
commandes c'est pas un enjeu de
délocalisations comme j'ai pu l'entendre
tout renault souffre les il y a plus de
dix mille suppressions d'emplois en
dehors de france chez renault
et il n'est pas vrai de dire qu'il ya
des sites qui travaillent sept jours sur
sept et qui serait accablé par les
comment ce qu'il faut malheureusement
c'est un problème qui est globale
mondiale et qui n'est d'ailleurs pas
seulement inhérents à renault est ce
qu'un échange des 5 milliards de prêts
garantis par l'état il faut en demander
plus arnaud art on a entendu il ya la
préservation du site de maubeuge masque
il faut demander
il ya par exemple des relocalisations
plus clair quantifier sur des modèles
précis des préservation d'autres mais je
crois que nous avons obtenu des rôles
localisation précise
lorsqu'on dit que le moteur électrique
qui aurait dû être fabriqués en chine
sera fabriqué en france
c'est une avancée majeure ce sont des
gardes avec d'investissement c'est des
centaines de millions d'euros
d'investissements
ça c'est du concret moi je ne me nourris
pas de 10 des vagues d'incohérences je
regarde la réalité
je suis au service des salariés pour
maintenir les compétences sur le
territoire pour maintenir les sites mais
pour bâtir des sites pour un futur qui
est soutenable pas pour découvrir dans
trois ans quatre ans que ces sites
devront fermer parce que ils ne savent
pas faire face à la concurrence
eh bien merci beaucoup agnès pannier
ménages les avoir répondu à mes
questions
jma présent accueillir le président du
groupe uc le groupe union centriste
ici au sénat hervé marseille bonjour
bonjour
un mot d'abord et bien sûr cette séance
mouvementée qui a été marquée par le
départ de l'hémicycle de vos collègues
du groupe l air est ce que vous les
comprenez oui bien sûr je comprends pas
naturel de sortir d'un hémicycle au
parlement il faut qu'ils aient été un
peu énervé il faut dire que la réponse
était pas vraiment à la hauteur de
ce qu'on pouvait attendre je veux dire
la porte parole du gouvernement nous a
habitués à des sorties inappropriée je
pense que la réponse n'était pas au
niveau je comprends que mes collègues et
amis du du groupe henner ce soit un peu
énervé et soit sorti parce qu'il faut
que l'état reste impartial politique
politicienne ne me disais à l'instant
agnès panière une hache et elle juge
elle que la polémique qui est soulevée
justement par la droite sénatoriale
elle n'est pas au niveau dans le
contexte de crise à chacun se renvoie
les arguments côté quand les ministres
se déplacent et quand même pas normal
que les parlementaires soient invités
alors il ya un contexte particulier avec
la crise mais les prêts faits sont
suffisamment fins habituellement
peut-être pas celui du doubs met
habituellement pour faire en sorte que
les choses se passent bien et qu'on
trouve des solutions consensuelles
on en arrive finalement un sujet qu'on a
évoqué à plusieurs reprises un pendant
toute cette période du confinement la
question des droits du parlement
finalement pendant cette période
lorsque vous voyez tout de même la
réduction par exemple du nombre
d'ordonnancés le dernier projet de loi
sur laquelle il ya eu un accord entre
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat vous
réjouissez le gouvernement quand même
reculer sur ce sujet là oui et même
l'assemblée nationale est intervenue de
son côté avec le sénat pour que l'on
limite
l'intervention de l'exécutif ce qui est
préoccupant
peut-être ne l'avez vous pas vu c'est
que le 17 juin est inscrit à l'agenda de
l'assemblée nationale la prolongation de
l'état d'urgence la prolongation de
l'état d'urgence
ça veut dire qu'au moment où on
s'apprête à voter
certes il va y avoir un nouvel avis du
conseil scientifique
oui mais on va voter normalement si tout
va bien le 28 juin et bien le 17 on
inscrit à l'assemblée nationale la
prolongation de l'état d'urgence
allez qui comprend que quelque chose
soit on veut pas que les électeurs se
déplacent alors c'est pas la peine de
jouer sur les procurations et de
favoriser le vote soit l'administration
et d'exécuter veulent à toute force
continue à diriger le pays sans
intermédiaire sans parlement 100
personnes et on n'y comprend plus rien
donc il n'est pas normal qu'on continue
à gérer le pays de cette façon justement
vous aviez eu hier et bien l'adoption
d'une proposition de loi pour sécuriser
pour simplifier les procurations
elle a intégré un texte que vous même
vous aviez écrit notamment avec bruno
retailleau ce texte que dit il tout
simplement ils essaient de faire en
sorte qu'on puisse être plus nombreux à
participer au second tour en favorisant
la double procuration c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui ne peut pas
voter ne peut faire qu'une procuration
et nous on veille à ce qu'il y ait deux
procurations
ensuite on veille à ce que par exemple
les personnes âgées puissent demander un
parent un un petit fils à quelqu'un qui
n'habitent pas nécessairement sa ville
de venir voter pour elle de façon à ce
que son vote puisse être pris en compte
voilà on essaie de favoriser la
participation n'est c'est faire en sorte
que tout le monde puisse voter et il est
dommage que le gouvernement je les y en
eu seconde pas cette démarche lui il ya
peu de chances pour que ce soit inscrit
à l'ordre du jour à l'assemblée
nationale avant le 28 juin était alors
on nous en parlons nous ne le savons pas
mais en tous les cas le sénat a fait en
sorte qu'ils aient une réponse à la
participation
c'est au gouvernement de prendre la
balle au bond c'est au gouvernement
c'est la balle est dans le camp du
gouvernement
merci beaucoup r&d marseille d'avoir
répondu à mes questions
parmi les autres temps forts en tout à
l'heure de la séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement il ya eu
bien sûr et bien des questions autour de
la situation
de renault rno un bien sûr qui est en
crise je vous propose tout de suite
d'écouter un extrait de cette séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
il faut faire en sorte que chaque faute
et il peut y en avoir
chaque accès chaque mot y compris des
expressions racistes fasse l'objet d'une
enquête fasse l'objet d'une décision
fasse l'objet d'une sanction et je suis
sur ce sujet intransigeant parce que
l'exigence que nous avons vis-à-vis des
policiers qui faudrait c'est garantir
justement la sérénité du travail de
l'ensemble de la police et de la
gendarmerie c'est garantir la défense de
cette police républicaine qui au
quotidien combat combat le racisme
combat l'antisémitisme et s'engage au
quotidien pour défendre l'honneur de la
république
c'est ça qui est essentielle et il ne
s'agit pas de faire des amalgames mais
il s'agit effectivement de dénoncer tout
propos ou tout comportement s'il ya
faute
elle doit être sanctionnée et elles sont
sanctionnées
c'était un extrait des séances de
questions d'actualité consacré aussi à
la question des violences policières et
la réponse du ministre de l'intérieur
christophe castaner je suis avait à
présent avec le président de la
commission des finances le sénateur
socialiste vincent eblé
vincent eblé un mot tout d'abord et bien
sûr la situation de renault
hier le prêt garanti par l'état 2 5
milliards d'euros pour renault a été
signé à ce que c'est pour vous une bonne
chose on le sait c'est vital aujourd'hui
pourrait bien ce fleuron de l'industrie
automobile française
je pense qu'aucun gouvernement ne peut
se désintéresser de l'avenir de la
filière automobile qui est absolument
déterminante pour l'économie française
et singulièrement pour l'entreprise
renault qui hélas de nos fleurons en la
matière donc oui il fallait réagir il
faut que l'état intervienne
et finalement si la situation n'était
pas aussi grave
ce serait avec un certain amusement
qu'on verrait les chantres d'une
économie libérale où finalement on
prônait la faible intervention de l'état
être obligé
nécessité faisant loi de d'intervenir à
ce niveau donc vous êtes d'accord avec
ce prêt de 5 milliards est-ce que les
garanties obtenues en échange sont pour
vous suffisante il ya la question des
dividendes
il ya aussi la question de la
préservation du site de maubeuge mais on
le voit est bien néanmoins il y a
aujourd'hui il ya des sites en grève
notamment celui bien sûr de choisy le
roi vous savez les garanties on les
définit de façon préalable mais c'est un
posteriori qu'on peut en juger la
pertinence et j'irai le caractère
véritablement complet donc nous
attendrons que l'expérience nous dise si
finalement dans cette affaire j'irai les
intérêts de cette filière de l'économie
française et des salariés du groupe
renault ont bien été défendue vincent
eblé autre inquiétude
en cette période de crise le déficit
très préoccupant de la sécurité sociale
situation directement lié aux qu'ovide
52,2 milliards d'euros en 2020 on voit
une nouvelle fois s'éloigne et bien là
l'idée du retour à l'équilibré
que faut-il faire pour vous c'est
inquiétant oui c'est inquiétant parce
que sous le
quinquennat précédent nous avions réussi
à redresser sensiblement les comptes de
la sécurité sociale
aujourd'hui c'est une dégradation alors
bien sûr on peut considérer que l est
gyr est la conséquence de la crise
sanitaire que le monde entier vient de
traverser et travers son corps d'une
certaine façon mais il y à une
préoccupation plus largement il ya une
préoccupation sur le financement de
l'action publique et les besoins que
nous constituer en ressentent et exprime
à juste titre et donc nous devons agir
est travaillé aussi c'est de l'une des
propositions que nous faisons dans cette
actualité sur la question des ressources
et d'une certaine comment dire
restauration de l'égalité et les
français devant la contribution fiscale
devant l'impôt vous proposez d'ailleurs
un isf 2.0 c'est une nouvelle
contribution pour les plus riches
sur quels principes nous allons chercher
une appellation qui j'irai indique que
nous n'étions pas dans la volonté de
restaurer un dispositif anciens mais
bien d'imaginer un dispositif nouveau
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
allons commencer à appeler notre
proposition impôt de solidarité sur la
fortune 2.0 désormais nous l'appelant
impôt de solidarité sur le capital et
nous considérons en effet qu'il est
nécessaire d'aller chercher parmi j'irai
ceux de nos compatriotes qui bénéficient
j'irai de la détention de capital et de
fortune extrêmement élevé une part
contributive qui rétablissent giresse
cette équité devant l'impôt pris nos
concitoyens la crise et gilet jaune
avant les nécessités de couverture des
charges publiques de la crise due qu'aux
villes l'ont démontré j'irai ont
considéré comme ayant été j'irai
abandonné
c'est le débat à l'ordre du jour
aujourd'hui dans l'hémicycle merci
beaucoup
vincent eblé d'avoir répondu à la
question j'accueille à présent la
présidente us et de la commission de la
culture et de l'éducation catherine
morin desailly bonjour bonjour merci de
répondre à mes questions
la situation des écoles
bien sûr continue d'inquiéter
d'inquiéter les français qu est ce qu
elle vous inquiète jean michel blanquer
a fait valoir que quasiment tous les
établissements sont ouverts sauf qu'ils
sont loin très loin de pouvoir
accueillir tous les élèves et bien
entendu puisqu'il ya un protocole
sanitaire qui s'applique à tous les
établissements scolaires qui exige une
distanciation qui exige moins d'élèves -
enfants par classe donc c'est une
réouverture progressive concertée qui a
été annoncé par le ministre et du
cassiot nationale et qui est qui est en
cours
bien entendu si la situation est si les
conditions sanitaires de l'épidémie
devait perdurer il y aurait un vrai
sujet pour la rentrée en septembre
parce que on peut penser qu'il faut
vraiment et c'est impératif accueillir
tous les élèves et en l'état aura ton
assez de locaux aura ton assez aussi de
force humaine je pense forcément aux
enseignants mais aussi aux forces des
collectivités territoriales les agents
territoriaux
tout ça c'est une série de questions et
encore le grand flou pour septembre vous
êtes encore inquiète pour le mois de
septembre même si c'est une allocation
cellule pour tous j'allais dire c'est le
flou pour le domaine sportif pour le
domaine culturel pour un certain nombre
d'activités pour ce qui concerne
l'éducation dans toute sa dimension
parce que c'est l'école primaire c'est
le lycée c'est aussi jusqu'à
l'enseignement supérieur dans la mesure
où il y à l'agrégation aussi de public
il faut trouver les bonnes conditions
mais j'avais dire que ce qui se passe en
ce moment et ce qui se passe plutôt bien
parce que les élus s'impliquent
énormément il faut le rendent hommage
tout le monde y va du sien les
enseignants aussi et bien ce qui se
passe maintenant c'est aussi un test
pour le mois de septembre
c'est pour tester certaines le
conditions et voir comment on pourra
s'adapter pour l'instant tout est
suspendu en réalité à la reprise ou non
de l'épidémie on peut tous espéré que
l'épidémie est derrière nous et qu'on
puisse voilà préparer une rentrée de
manière plus tranquille et pour plus de
ram et je pourrais dire que dans
l'entrefaite il y aura ce qu'on appelle
les centres de loisirs les colonies de
vacances
il ya aussi toute cette jeunesse qui
d'habitude trouvent là des lieux
d'occupation des temps d'occupation
pendant des vacances et ça aussi c'est
un sujet vote en commission a travaillé
sur la situation des directeurs d'école
quelles sont les difficultés auxquelles
ils font face aujourd'hui et votre piste
pour pouvoir améliorer ils livrèrent les
directeurs d'école ont été largement à
la manoeuvre sur toute cette période de
crise à la demande de la commission par
mes collègues max brisson et françoise
laborde et le plongement d'un travail
type sur le statut de l'enseignant qui
mérite d'être valorisé le statut des
directeurs d'école est problématique en
réalité il n'y a pas de statut
intellectuelle école c'est un enseignant
au sein d'une école qui est volontaire
pour prendre en charge un certain nombre
de tâches administratives est le
référent en quelque sorte des
institutions de la mairie de
l'inspection et c est l immense tas et
documents sachent qu'il ya en plus des
heures de cours qui est très faiblement
dédommager et surtout qui prend du temps
et comme il faut conjuguer la fois
l'enseignement et ses tâches
administratives
on arrive parfois à des situations
extrêmement difficiles très lourdes il
faut clarifier tout cela ne serait ce
que pour aussi susciter des vocations de
directions d'école voilà parce que
toute peine mérite salaire mais aussi et
surtout exige des conditions de bon
exercice de cette fonction de direction
un mot enfin sur bien sûr le secteur de
la culture
les théâtres vont pouvoir rouvrir mais
dans quelles conditions comment le
spectacle vivant le cinéma et c'est à ce
que vous continuez à être inquiète ce
malgré ces signaux d'ouverture que l'on
sent
je suis très inquiète des répercussions
économiques en réalité deux de ces deux
trois mois d'arrêt brutal de l'activité
culturelle bien entendu il y aura des
conséquences il va falloir qu'on les ait
valu des plans d'urgence ont été votées
par le ministère par les régions par les
départements par un certain nombre de
collectivités mais que c'est suffisant
pour vous les voilà qui on aimerait bien
sûr ça suffira et donc il faut aussi se
poser toutes ces questions pour l'heure
ce qui est important c'est de commencer
à réouvrir aussi progressivement dotés
d'un protocole salita salutaire à
l'instar de ce qui a été fait pour
l'éducation nationale
je sais que la profession du spectacle
vivant à travailler avec les services du
ministère à l'élaboration de ce le
protocole sanitaire
ce dont on a besoin en réalité les
structures c'est de lisibilité
d'anticipation savoir comment ils
s'organisent alors que des nouvelles
saisons vont être lancées à partir du
mois de septembre
c'est maintenant que se prennent les
abonnements ou non donc ces structures
ont deux ans aussi de dire à leurs
spectateurs à leurs habituelles voilà ce
qui va se passer à la rentrée elles sont
prêtes à s'adapter en réalité elles ont
fait preuve aussi une réactivité de
propositions culturelles assez forte
y compris via le numérique pendant cette
période mais elles ont besoin
d'anticipation maintenant et il faudra
qu'on soit extrêmement attentifs un
secteur qui était très sinistrée un
secteur très sinistré merci beaucoup à
catherine morin desailly d'avoir répondu
à mes questions et nous allons conclure
cette émission avec est bien le
président de la commission de la défense
et des affaires étrangères le sénateur
christian cambon qui va venir prendre
votre place merci catherine morin
desailly bonjour christian cambon on va
parler bien d'une actualité grave qui a
marqué cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
la sphère john floyd aux états unis tout
d'abord qu'avez-vous pensez vous de la
réaction de donald trump
face à cette affaire son ton
martial le fait qu'il veuille
éventuellement recourir à l'armée ce
sont des propos qui divisent énormément
du côté des états unis
écoutez c'est une situation qui est
effectivement assez assez étonnant parce
que d'abord ce n'est pas donald trump
qui a importé le racisme qui existe aux
états unis depuis des dizaines d'années
depuis si longtemps
néanmoins on est frappé de du genre de
réaction que le président des états unis
a car dans une situation telle que celle
là où le pays est en train de
s'enflammer on est on pourrait
s'attendre à des appels au calme et à la
sérénité alors qu'on a un mouvement et
ce n'est pas l'impression que chaque
intervention consiste à mettre de
l'huile sur le feu et confier la
direction des opérations à un militaire
montrer tous ces gens treillis faire
sortir des armes lourdes
les menacée d'une répression sanglante
je pense que c'est évidemment très grave
enfin pour nous ici en europe ce serait
se serait ressenti véritablement comme
une situation impossible
on ne peut pas exclure qu'il y a une
démarche de politique intérieure et qui
s'adresse à une majorité silencieuse
toujours désireuse d'ordre ce qui est le
cas aux états unis dont une partie de
son électorat par la note de fermeté
extrême pour voir on se souvient du raid
a montré l'étendue d'un épisode est
identique avec l'élection de nixon qui
était revenu pour mettre de l'ordre
après des manifestations mais je pense
que néanmoins ça donne de très mauvais
signaux on envoie du rêve des
conséquences dans d'autres pays y
compris dans le nôtre ou tel ou tel
groupe essaie de surfer sur cette
actualité
mais je trouve évidemment que c'est
assez inquiétant de la part d'un des
chefs d'état les plus importants du
monde
christian cambon la sphère john floyd
est elle comparable à la faire adama
traoré
peut-on faire un parallèle c'est ce que
pense en tout cas les gens qui étaient
hier dans la rue les manifestants hier
écouter sincèrement je ne le pense pas
je pense qu'il ya en france une histoire
une identité et
une acceptation d'une situation qui n'a
strictement rien de comparable avec ce
qui se passe aux etats unis
il a pu y avoir moi je ne suis pas ni la
justice ni la police il a pu y avoir des
errements ou d attitude critiquable
les gouvernements successifs ont
toujours sanctionné ce genre de choses
et la justice tout autant je pense qu'il
est assez dangereux de surfer sur cette
actualité américaines pour essayer de
relancer en france
une agitation autour de ce cas qui a été
certainement dramatique mais je pense
que ni les circonstances ni les modes
d'intervention ni du reste les sanctions
qui frappent en france les policiers ne
sont comparables avec la violence qui a
lieu aux états unis où je rappelle que
les arrestations sont dix fois plus
importante des noirs que des blancs
c'est franchement on peut pas dire que
ça en france jugé qu il n'y a pas ce
même problème de racisme colonial dans
l'amour informons nous savons très bien
il ya dans tous les pays il y a
les germes d'un racisme et qui est
latent dans un certain nombre de nos
concitoyens il faut le combattre et mais
je pense qu'il ne faut pas utiliser et
surfer sur cette affaire dramatique qui
enflamme les états unis pour essayer
d'enflammer la france est à tout le
moins si on manifeste
je crois que ce n'est pas l'occasion
pour recommencer à brûler des boutiques
à voler des commerces au moment où notre
économie est déjà quasiment à genoux
je pense que sur ce plan là il ya aussi
des leçons à tirer une toute dernière
question christian cambon autour de
l'incident qu'il ya eu tout à l'heure
lors de la séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
le départ de l'hémicycle du groupe lr
votre groupe proteste contre le fait que
les visites ministérielles n'est pas
convié des parlementaires de
l'opposition sur place
le gouvernement tout à l'heure et
notamment en espagne et une hache et a
répondu un conditions sanitaires voilà
qui sont très restrictives
et deuxièmement elle jugé que c'était de
la politique politicienne qu'est ce que
vous en pensez que là en l'occurrence
moi j'essaye de toujours modérée dans
mes jugements mais je pense que la
réponse de la porte parole du
gouvernement a été excessivement
malhabile
il ya quand même des témoignages de
plusieurs départements où les préfets
dissuade des sénateurs et des sénateur
n'appartenant pas
marsh d'être présent nous avons des
photos mon collègue grosperrin est en
mesure de diffuser une photo ou un
préfet en uniforme
le shass le chas d'une manifestation
mémorielle ce n'est pas acceptable ce
n'est pas il ya un député ganna
sénateurs un sénateur de l'opposition
égale un député de la majorité
et je crois que le gouvernement fait un
faux calcul de se lancer dans une
affaire pareille la courtoisie
parlementaire pour tout le monde comme
la nôtre nous nous sommes là pour
écouter les ministres je pense que c'est
que c'est ça la république eh bien merci
beaucoup christian cambon d'avoir
répondu à mes questions
c'est la fin de ce débrief des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
merci à tous d'avoir suivi cette
émission on se retrouvait bien la
semaine prochaine 14h50 pour une
prochaine séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement très bonne
soirée sur les chaînes parlementaires
[Musique]